[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
the body of the late congressman john
lewis will arrive on capitol hill later
today
where he will lie in state this week
yesterday lewis made
one final journey just one across the
historic edmond pettis bridge in selma
alabama
his flag draped casket was carried on a
horse-drawn wagon
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller has been in alabama to
witness a very emotional send-off
she joins us from the statehouse in
montgomery michelle i watched all
weekend saturday and sunday it was so
tender and so touching and so
well deserved good morning to you
good morning indeed it was the 80 year
old civil rights icon was honored
certainly remembered yesterday and that
casket
carrying his body arrived here at the
alabama state capitol
here in montgomery where the public paid
its respects
it was especially poignant because this
was the intended end of
end of the 1965 march for voting rights
and that peaceful march as you well know
was
ended or ended rather in what has become
known
as bloody sunday
two horses pulled the flag draped casket
of civil rights leader john lewis
through the streets of selma
as a crowd gathered to watch some
chanting his motto
good trouble as he was carried across
the alabama river
one last time my life
is better selma is better
this nation and this world are better
because of john robert lewis
congresswoman terry sewell led sunday's
prayer service
she called lewis a friend a mentor and a
hero
this is personal for you very personal
to walk in the footsteps of john lewis
with john lewis
that's a treat of a lifetime and i got
to do it over and over again
cheyenne webb kreisberg was at the foot
of the bridge sunday
she'd been there before with john lewis
in 1965 cheyenne was just eight years
old
the youngest marcher that day she too
was met with
tear gas by alabama state troopers what
does it mean for you to be here today
when i look at what happened on the
bloody sunday march
in the 60s people were beaten by the
troopers
and the policemen but today
we will see congressman lewis take his
last march
and he's being embraced he's being
escorted by them
and he deserves that and the picture of
bloody sunday
has never left my heart neither my mind
people who never met lewis were also
compelled to be here
like the bulgers who wanted their little
girls to witness history
they said goodbye as state troopers
saluted the man their predecessors had
attacked
and then as three-year-old madison
bulger struggled for a view
state trooper bubba bell swept her up
into his shoulders
validation perhaps of john lewis's long
hard fight that was a sign
that we're heading in headed in the
right direction and it was a sign to him
that his work was not in vain
of course recent events have showed us
that we have yet further to go
but the work the passion the sacrifice
of leaders like
lewis certainly propelled us further
ahead to a better place
a better place than this was in 1965
and 150 years before that when
montgomery was the capital
of the confederacy gail
michelle how lovely that you had
cheyenne to talk to all these years
later
the scene that got me was where the
troopers saluting him when years ago he
had been beaten by the troopers i saw
the services from his family who always
called him robert
and one sister told the story when he
left home to go see dr martin luther
king his mother said
don't get into trouble don't get in the
way and they said we all knew that he
would do something
good trouble from a very good man
yes he was thank you michelle miller
later today we'll bring you live special
coverage right here on cbs on cbsn
on the arrival of the casket caring
congressman john lewis in washington
for public viewing at the u.s capitol